[pensive violin music]
This is a satellite image
of the Mojave Desert in the US.
It's a fragile desert ecosystem...
dotted with wildflower fields
and Joshua trees
which are iconic in this region.
But over the past several years
the landscape has started
to change.
If you take a closer look in certain areas
you start to see more and more
of these patches of blue.
They’re are solar farms.
And in this part of the US
many environmental activists
and local residents
are not happy about them.
“Joshua trees are torn down to
make way for solar projects.”
“... causing quite an uproar...”
“...piles and piles of Joshua trees.”
It isn't just the trees.
Solar farms in rural areas can take up
valuable agricultural land and
disrupt diverse ecosystems.
But transitioning to more solar power
and a more sustainable future
for the US
requires a lot of land.
So, what if we could find some of that land
inside our cities?
[Urgent piano music]
This video is presented
by Delta Airlines.
In 2021, President Biden announced
ambitious plans for the US
to achieve net-zero greenhouse
gas emissions
economy-wide by no later than 2050.
Solar is a critical part of the plan.
And over the past several years
as the US has ramped up
solar power generation...
the vast majority of solar arrays
have been built in rural areas.
According to one study
over half of utility scale
solar facilities
were placed in deserts.
Another third in croplands.
10% in grasslands and forests.
And just 2.5% in urban areas.
That makes sense.
Putting solar on undeveloped
open spaces is often
is often the cheapest and
fastest way to do it.
But there are some major problems
with this path.
Large scale installations
often mean bulldozing
massive amounts of land...
altering plant and animal growth
and migration patterns.
Or locals don't want a solar farm
to ruin natural views.
Or they want to preserve farmland.
When you start to go bigger and bigger...
then it starts to become
less comfortable for people.
That's Joshua Pearce.
He's been a photovoltaics researcher
for two decades
and is a professor at the University
of Western Ontario.
And so we've seen progressively
more and more resistance
in the middle of the US...
to large scale solar development.
That resistance has sometimes
been funded
by fossil fuel companies...
but people also have
legitimate concerns.
And across the country
from Massachusetts to Ohio
to California...
solar expansion has been stalled
by protests.
One option that we're starting
to see more of is agrovoltaics.
It's a way to build solar arrays
that allow for agricultural use
between the panels...
to preserve some farmland for crops,
grazing, or native species.
But because the need for energy
is mostly outside of rural areas...
any kind of rural solar still means building
long distance transmission lines
that can be expensive
and an eyesore.
One thing that can help address
some of these issues
would be a kind of large, open,
unused space closer to cities.
Enter: Parking lots.
The US has a lot of them...
thanks to decades of designing cities
around cars.
Parking lots cover over 5%
of developed land.
These spaces could play one part
in helping to fix solar’s land problem...
if we covered the lots in canopies
of solar panels.
There is an awful lot of
parking lot space
in the United States that we can
take advantage of
that's already essentially unused.
It’s wasted space except for
parking underneath it.
And it's not even used
most of the time.
It's an idea that other
parts of the world
like France, are embracing.
A 2023 policy in France will require that
outdoor car parks with
more than 80 spaces...
cover at least half the surface area
with solar canopies.
And officials estimate it could add
ten nuclear power plants’ worth
of solar panels.
Importantly, policy like this utilizes space
that's already cleared land
with little biodiversity...
which is also close to consumers.
And parking lot solar canopies
could also provide shade
to cars in hot weather and
cover from snow.
So why don't we see more parking lot canopies
in the US, too?
Like canopies that could cover
Disney World parking lots.
Instead of the solar farms they built
on nearby land
that used to be orchards
and forests.
Or covering some of LA's
many parking lots
instead of overbuilding in the desert.
Well, the biggest obstacle to putting solar
on parking lots
is... cost.
The cost of putting in a solar canopy
is going to be 50%
to even 100% more than
a conventional solar farm.
The thing that makes canopies
more expensive
than a conventional solar farm is
they're higher up off the ground.
And so you need more structural material
and you also need more
weight at the bottom
holding them from blowing away.
And so why would a company
want to invest even more money
to put in a canopy?
They're actually is an answer
to that question.
In 2017, Pierce coauthored
a study looking into the economic
potential of parking lot canopies
and used Walmart Supercenters
as a case study.
The study found that in places
with high solar flux
or more solar radiation
in the area...
solar canopies could be
incredibly profitable.
Like here in Phoenix, Arizona.
But they also found that
even in areas in the US
considered to have less solar flux,
like here in Michigan...
selling solar back to the grid
at going rates...
could still be profitable enough
to make solar canopies worth it
in the long run.
It really goes down to...
how much are you paying
for electricity...
and how much solar flux do you have?
And most of the US, barring
Northern Alaska
actually has fairly good solar fluxes.
I grew up in western Pennsylvania
which has some of the worst
and systems are still
economic there.
In another 2021 study,
Pearce and his team
found the total capacity across all US
Wal-Mart Supercenters
would be 11.1 gigawatts
of solar power.
That's around the high estimate
of what the French parking lot program
expects to make.
With that power...
Wal-Mart could power about
100 electric vehicle charging stations
at each Wal-Mart location...
or if they combine the canopies
with rooftop solar
there would likely be more than enough
to power the stores.
It would also create the opportunity
to sell power
back to utility companies
on the main grid...
or stores could be the anchor
for a local microgrid
in the community
offering power to homes
in the case of outages.
This isn't a one size fits all solution...
but in good locations where companies
can afford the upfront cost of installation.
Pearce’s research shows canopy's
could be a worthwhile investment.
It's guaranteed under warranty
to generally work for 25 years.
That's an investment.
You're investing in capital asset
and it’s providing you a return
over its lifetime.
You should treat it the same way you would
any other investment.
Only this one is actually good for the planet
at the same time.
In some parts of the US
institutions like airports and universities
are already trying solar parking lots.
Walmart and Target
are just beginning to try them out
in certain stores
and policy is slowly catching up too...
to make these kinds of solar projects easier...
like Maryland offering grants for solar canopies...
and a New York City zoning proposal...
that would allow for solar on
more than 8500 acres
of parking lots.
Parking lots can't fix solar’s
land scarcity problem
on their own.
The amount of solar production we need
will likely require
a combination of efforts,
including in rural areas...
utility-scale arrays
canopies where we can put them
arrays on rooftops...
and in other places like along highways
over landfills or
on degraded lands.
But solar canopies are part of
a large toolbox...
that could put a huge dent in our reliance
on fossil fuels...
and point to a future where more cities...
are finding ways to give new life...
to some of America's most overlooked spaces.